j'entendais oui vous êtes notre meilleur
expert en matière de comics au cinéma
côté à prendre votre longue carrière
jusqu'à vous avez autant de vent vous
autour dernier film c'est le complexe de
cinéma oui je veux terminer les
campagnes de finalement sous la
direction de jean boyer d'après la pièce
de bernard luc oui avec sandra milo
comme les scindera milo puis beaucoup de
camarades de classe
avez vous noté une évolution dans le
comics pour l'écran depuis un certain
nombre d'années depuis adam guerre par
exemple eh bien je crois que on arrive à
une humanité dans le comique parce que
dans le comics on a toujours poussé des
fins ce qu'on appelait chargé et en
termes de métiers on appelait ça les
chargeurs réunis
lorsqu'on faisait un film où vraiment
nous les comics que nous faisions rire
avec
- personnellement lorsque j'ai fait des
films avant la guerre à dieu sait j'en
ai fait beaucoup et bien j'ai fait des
interprétations de personnages avec des
si la balle n'est ce pas ou j'appuyais
gpat dont qu'est ce que c'était n'est ce
pas
c'était drôle maintenant nous sommes
arrivés avec l'époque actuelle surtout
depuis la libération petit à petit on a
évolué dans le comique et on est arrivé
à a joué tellement naturel et je crois
que le succès d'un film même comique
c'est ça ce que nous avons en effet
prouvé que vous étiez un comédien
complet en tournant des rôles
dramatiques ce qui a priori semble plus
facile car il est plus difficile
toujours de faire rire vous avez tourné
par exemple toute une série de films de
pagnol comme angèle le schpountz vous
avez tourné meurtre ou à détourner le
fruit défendu et plus près de nous la
vache et le prisonnier
oui mais alors je vous dirais que
naturellement lorsque l'on fait un film
dramatique je dirais traumatique ou
alors les pagnol qui étaient des films
où il y avait des scènes dramatiques et
des scènes comiques mais ça pagnol avait
le secret vous savez que pagnol est un
des plus grands auteurs de notre époque
enfin pour moi c'est le molière de notre
époque je sais que s'il m'entend
aujourd'hui il ne sera pas content parce
qu'ils n'aiment pas que je dise
il est menteur mais vous savez que tous
les méridionaux sont menteurs n'y a pas
de raison que je dise que pagnol
n'allait pas de soi c'est son mensonge
permanente qui m'a permis d'ailleurs de
faire des films aussi formidable
lorsqu'il les a tournées avec moi car
lorsqu'on tourne avec pagnol
ce n'était pas du cinéma que l'on
faisait une langue aux joueurs bull ont
des gelées le matin ont déjà le midi
très souvent le soir qu'on lève à
tourner et on repartait il me disait
alors à demain et le lendemain on
repartait c'est comme ça que vous en
fais des films mais c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont fait en gel regain le
schpountz topaz tous nous on fait des
films avec pagnol en ami c'est à dire
que nous rencontrons et si on avait le
temps on faisait du cinéma
quelle est la raison qui vous a fait
dire il ya quelques instants que pagnol
est un menteur parce que tous les
méridionaux son moteur moi aussi je suis
mais il n'y a pas un exemple précis où
ils vous ai menti non c'est à dire que
vous avez pagnol et le type qui vous dit
tu es formidable
après le dis c'est pas vrai mais ils
pensent que je suis formidable mais
toute ma vie il m'a fait ça on peut pas
lui en vouloir
et quand les gens me disent est ce que
vous êtes fâché avec bagnols je vais
mais on ne se fâche au pas avec bagnols
avec pagnol et toujours ami où on est
toujours fâché il ya une association qui
a qui a réussi c'est l'association
fernandel bourvil pour un film
commercial mais un bon film comique
commercial la cuisine au beurre aux
messieurs ça très bien réussi et jour
dire pourquoi parce que d'abord nous
manquons de films comiques en ce moment
depuis quelques années on a peur de
faire rire en france vous avez remarqué
que mes jeunes camarades qui sont dans
le cinéma et qui ont beaucoup de talent
très souvent dit oh non c'est comique
ils ont tort vous avez qu à regarder que
les comics qui font des films drôles un
certain succès même si le film est un
petit film parce que les gens veulent
mourir
et lorsqu'on a annoncé la cuisine au
beurre avec nous deux n'est ce pas on
s'est dit tiens de comics là on va
rigoler c'est tout ce que nous voulions
il est pourtant une association beaucoup
plus importante qui au départ et tonnes
il c'est celle de fernandel et de jean
gabin ah oui mais alors massés c'est ça
étonne doublement parce que en plus de
l'association des deux axes
ils deviennent producteurs tous les deux
justement à ce que c'est ça qui est
étonnant qui a eu l'idée de cette
association
ces gamins au départ et moi l'arrivée
bien sûr il faut être deux donc il ya
pas mal à parler parce que n'est ce pas
le départ cette association ses 35 ans
d'amitié
nous avons débuté avec gabin tous les
deux dans le music hall et puis nous
avons fait du cinéma presque en même
temps au début du parlant et nous avons
fait trois films ensemble avec gabin
nous avons fait les guettait de
l'escadron paris béguin et coeur de
glace et si nous avons suivi une
carrière différente en tant qu'acteur
nous nous sommes toujours vu toujours
rencontrer nous en gardons regarder
cette mamie si affectueuses nous avions
au départ et comme nous sommes de la
vieille vague je crois les deux seuls
qui restent nous avons décidé de créer
une maison de production et pour ça nous
on choisit notre nom pour les deux
premières syllabes de notre nom nous
voulions prendre l'autre nom de famille
il s'appelle moncorgé je m'appelle
contandin lorsqu'elle nous sommes
aperçus ce que dans les deux premières
syllabes
nous avons pris notre nom d'acteur nous
avons fait la société qu'à faire elle
sans réaction contre les producteurs que
vous avez voulu devenir vous même
producteur or pas du tout parce que nous
pourrons pas vouloir aux producteurs
étant donné qu'ils nous on a tenté
beaucoup de choses dans notre vie
puisque nous avons fait notre carrière
d'abord par le public mais aussi par les
producteurs qui nous ont engagé parce
que c'est à paris les producteurs nous
allons jamais fait de cinéma
nous avons commencé au début du parlant
part des choses beaucoup moins
importante et puis lorsque nous sommes
arrivés à être peut-être chacun de notre
côté
gabin a fait pleurer et moi j'ai fait
rire et maintenant maintenant nous
allons essayer de faire pleurer et rire
tous les deux mais je suis certain que
jon que l'on dit avec un mauvais
caractère
ce n'est pas vrai je vais vous dire
gardien est un homme très amusant nous
ne passait plusieurs soirs un ensemble
parce que nous voyons presque tous les
jours étant donné que les associés sont
obligés de se rencontrer
dernièrement il était chez moi avec ça
la mienne est vraiment nous avons ri
beaucoup parce que jean est un homme qui
n'a pas eu très souvent à ses côtés dans
ses films
vu le sujet des gens drôles or je suis
certain que lorsque nous allons faire
notre premier film qui commence le 15
septembre
nous allons avoir l'ambiance
l'atmosphère des films amusant avec un
personnel certainement amusant ce qui
nous empêchera pas d'avoir des scènes
humaine et que gabin avec son grand
talent nous apporte dans ce film sa
personnalité et moi amiens avez vous une
idée de ce que sera le scénario de ce
film nous allons faire un film sur un
roméo et juliette moderne
je ne veux pas pour l'instant vous
donner le nouveau départ mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que gabin aura
trois ou quatre filles et moi j'aurais
trop quatre fils
ce qui nous permettra dans le film de
dire toi des garçons ne l'a pas eue
emmanuel iii défini long play
l'internement et je peux vous dire que
le fils sera jouée par le même temps
dire que j'en profite puisque je lai
lorsque d'autres en premier rôle se
retrouvent dans un même film
n'est-il pas parfois des questions de
préséance qui risque de jouer
non non pas du tout pas du tout
lorsqu'il est arrivé à ce que nous
sommes arrivés
si nous allons encore regardé la
grosseur du nom sur la fiche celui
qu'elle premier celui qu'elle deuxième
il faut quand même avec deux personnages
kahniens qu'ils soient premiers alors
que ça soit fernandel gabin ou gabin
fernandel et tout ça on m'a dit comment
allez-vous vous entendre les regarder
dans un américain amérique ils sont
quatre vedettes
il ya toujours un premier un deuxième un
troisième un quatrième ça n'a pas
d'importance d'ailleurs le public ne
s'intéresse pas à ça pour que le public
vienne sur deux noms connus sur un sujet
est la première des choses de faire un
bon film au départ avec gabin je ne
crois pas que nous payons ça vous paraît
paradoxal car on dit tellement des
choses des vedettes on dit sont les
vedettes
n'est ce pas si au départ empêche de
faire un grand film parce qu'ils
prennent trop eh bien nous nous le
prendrons rien d'autant plus vous êtes
vos producteurs
oui
mais c'est pas une raison pour aller
tourner et gratuit bien sûr si nous
faisons les producteurs pour le plus
touché d'argent c'est pas la peine
nous ne payons pas au départ non ce sera
un beau but il ya un certain nombre
d'années faire d'antenne que vous faites
des films que l'on peut considérer comme
les films surtout commerciaux nous nous
ont pas pourquoi vous dites ça un
certain nombre d'années non j'ai fait
quelques films commerciaux oui parce que
à mon avis dans le cinéma il n'y a pas
deux poids et deux mesures on doit ferme
où le grand film dramatique comme
meurtre comme la vache et le prisonnier
ou comme le fruit défendu
ou alors on doit faire le film qui amuse
mais il ne faut pas faire le film
entre les deux c'est à dire le film où
l'on attend la grande scène d'émotion et
la grande scène comique qui ne viennent
jamais alors je préfère que lorsque les
spectateurs en sortant disent oh oh
c'était idiot alors que jerry hall et au
moins ça ça se bat pour moi c'est une
réussite de le dire c'est vrai je n'ai
pas beaucoup rire je croyais quand même
oui oui ce que je dois dire la manip le
réunir et je crois que avec votre
télévision la scène pour le cinéma
nous devons faire des grands films des
grands films parce que je sais que
lorsque vous voyez le drian chez vous
c'est à vous téléspectateurs que je
m'adresse en ce moment oublié de vous
parler les yeux dans les yeux parce que
moi j'ai pas peur mais je suis comme ça
eh bien je suis un téléspectateur
quoiqu'étant du cinéma qu'est ce que
voulait il faut vivre avec son temps et
suivre le progrès eh bien je sais que
lorsque vous voyez un bon film vous
allez le voir mais il faut vous déranger
car ouvriers des beaux spectacles la
télévision pas toujours bien entendu
comme au cinéma pas toujours de bons
films
et lorsqu'il ya quelque chose de bien
pour rester chez vous ça quelque chose
de bien au cinéma vous sortez de chez
vous c'est le plaisir que je me souhaite
[Musique]